die nachrichten des tages heute mit
knappen stunde gegen olaf scholz dann
bei den männern gibt es heute und morgen
kommen daran hat ihr präsident keinen
beschluss kann das justizministerium
fast allem entschlossen ein grausamer
den auftritt des kanzlers der käufe und
wolken zur abwechslung mal aus boston
wiederwahl macros hat premierminister
die beiden dfb pokal halbfinals am abend
auf stabilisierung und wiederherstellung
doch vor die presse der druck war wohl
zweifel mehr
berufung einlegen
japan
ausnahmezustand die propaganda zeigt
krieg könnte in den nächsten tagen noch
heran und wenn sie ganz genau hinschauen
castings bereits eine
zu groß doch es gab keine ganz klaren
und darum jene menschen unterzubringen
verfolgt das unserem hauptstadtstudio
abend willkommen zu den nachrichten 20
trifft der hsv auf freiburg der
regierungsumbildung angekündigt macau
grausamer werden
einen ganz anderen weg in der pandemie
dann sehen sie nicht nur in blau
theo scholz stand ja sehr unter druck
tanzende bürger in der quarantäne
die ihr zuhause verloren haben
aussagen zum thema schwere geräte nur so
wir können jetzt sagen dass die
zweitligist aus hamburg kaum noch mit
und für uns vor ort in der ukraine ist
minuten natürlich auch mit sport und
regenfälle sondern auch in violett oder
liegt in umfragen vorne aber nur knapp
geht china die regierung verfolgt eine
wie bewerten sie denn dann sein auftritt
chancen auf den bundesliga-aufstieg
russischen kräfte nach langer
viel die ukraine werde weiter geld
zwar mit norbert lehmann taille
dominik lässt meister dominik die
im fall neuer card gibt es eine neue
und das sind viele nach jetzigem stand
dafür aber lockt das pokalfinale am 21
vorbereitung den kampf um das donbass
hose etwas schneeregen oder schnee der
thomas walde über das enge rennen
heute
gutmachen unsere großen themen heute
strategie aber omikron breitet sich
bekommen für den kauf von rüstungsgütern
würde war eben ein bundeskanzler unter
ukrainische armee hält jetzt ja seit
entwicklung und es geht um den
gestartet haben diese offensive wird
fiel im berchtesgadener land oder auch
nach ostern beginnt der endspurt in der
sind rund 40.000 menschen durch
und entscheidend sei dass zügig
über 50 tagen den angriffen stand jetzt
immer weiter aus in shanghai ist die
flüchtigen ex vorstand jan marschalek
berlin vor 35 jahren reckte kapitän
der kanzler bleibt dabei die ukraine
druck zu erleben ein bundeskanzler der
einen sehr großen teil ihrer armee
erdrutsche und überschwemmungen
geliefert wird zusätzlich sind wir
in den alten diese dichteren wolken hier
der schon länger in russland vermutet
diese grossoffensive wird die
arbeit der stadt lille versuchen
obdachlos geworden
zahl der toten auf zehn gestiegen
binden
erhält keine direkten lieferungen
bereit unsere nato partner die noch über
sich und seine ukraine haltung zu
im osten die beschäftigen uns auch noch
anhänger des präsidenten vor allem linke
wird die münchner staatsanwaltschaft hat
ukrainische armee weiter gegen halten
manni kaltz zum letzten mal für den hsv
seit ende märz müssen hier rund 26
schwerer waffen aus deutschland
erklären versucht hat die kurze
in der nacht im westen ist es dagegen
bilder auf twitter zeigen russische
arktische folgen der flutkatastrophe in
wähler zu gewinnen eine schwere aufgabe
können
waffensysteme verfügen die aus der
aber geld und waffen zu kaufen
sich ein bericht zufolge an die
den pokal in die höhe und das ist für
klar und an den alpen kann es etwas
pressekonferenz hatte durchaus auch
millionen menschen zu hause bleiben
panzer angeblich auf dem weg zur
südafrika und jetzt jetzt kommen wir zum
russische regierung gewandt und
ja präsident selensky hat heute gesagt
russischen produktion stammen in der
regnen die temperaturen sinken auf plus
trotzdem gibt es rund 20.000 neue fälle
die hamburger schon viel zu lange her
putin will ihn zwickt erzwingen die
etwas von selbstverteidigung man habe
frontlinie 11 bataillone zusätzlich habe
beantragt marschalek festzunehmen und
ukraine selbst genutzt werden und sofort
die menschen in den sozial schwachen
sport und fun mit dem dfb-pokal mit den
haben bock auf dieses spiel ist eine
drei grad auf rügen und -3 grad in der
die grüne wird kämpfen sie wird sich
auszuliefern
lange angekündigte offensive hat
pro tag die behörden reagieren rigoros
einsetzbar sind zu unterstützen das ist
doch seit beginn schon waffen geliefert
russland mobilisiert glauben die usa das
vierteln wurden vergessen makros der
er ist eine schlüsselfigur im wirecard
eine tolle plattform wir haben
begonnen das ziel die eroberung der
frauen format da steht er jetzt das
aber eben nur solche waffen die zügig
oberpfalz milder bleibt es in der
verteidigen und wenn man sich die
wie ulf röller berichtet
ausverkauftes haus der hsv muss heute
präsident der reichen er hat die
wäre grob geschätzt war bis zu 10.000
skandal der zusammenbruch des
ostukraine
uckermark und ganz im westen bei 6 bis 4
etwas was wir mit vielen anderen
finale ja die wolfsburgerinnen die
liefer und einsetzbar gewesen sein dabei
das chinesische fernsehen zeigt gerne
schlacht um kiew ansieht dort hatte die
soldaten mehr aber längst keine garantie
finanzdienstleisters gilt als grösster
hatten sich am sonntag gegen die bayern
grad das west-ost-gefälle bei den
und heißt null co wird auch 0
zusammen so machen die rufe nach
kaufkraft aller auch der armen um fünf
gewinnen denn nur ein erfolg könnte den
sei man in den eigenen beständen rasch
ukraine erfolg und die russischen
auf einen sieg glauben beobachter die
betrugsfall der deutschen
drohnen flüge von shanghai von oben soll
temperaturen beschäftigt uns auch noch
durchgesetzt gestern gewann der erste
schmerz über den erneuten nichtaufstieg
prozent erhöht und es gab einen
menschlichkeit im kampf gegen omikron
nachkriegsgeschichte und wir blicken
an grenzen gestoßen eine position die ja
schwerem gerät für die ukraine sie
morgen im osten bleibt es bei zehn bis
geringe moral der truppen die probleme
truppen mussten sich zurückziehen das
inflationsausgleich für alle
mildern die freiburger hingegen
ffc turbine potsdam sein halbfinalspiel
alles geordnet wirken die propaganda
wurden in den letzten tagen immer lauter
sperrt china in shanghai zehntausende
auch immer wieder kritisiert wird dass
nach südafrika dort hat präsident ramzan
lag vor allem an der hohen kampfes moral
maximal 15 grad eher kühl im westen wird
der koordination die probleme in der
schnuppern auf platz 5 weiter an den
der bundeskanzler handele zu langsam tue
infizierte in quarantäne lager
verbreitet bilder von helfern die
in leverkusen eine spannende begegnung
das so sei man werde so sagte scholz
logistik die kann man nicht so schnell
nach den verheerenden überschwemmungen
der ukraine sie haben ihr land
viele linke tun sich schwer sich
es bei 14 bis 19 grad etwas milder und
champions-league-plätzen und trainer
lebensmittel verteilen die quarantäne
verteidigt und das hat hier in kiew
zu wenig so der vorwurf selbst die
bei der alle tore durch elfmeter fielen
überwinden deshalb können wir davon
der vergangenen tage landesweit den
aber bei den osteuropäischen partnern
christian streich ist ein echter pokal
zwischen makro le pen und einer
es war ein von vielen seit langem
ausgehen dass es bodengewinne geben wird
ähnliche heute strahlt auch morgen in
zugesagte aufstockung der finanziellen
unterkünfte wirken wie hotels die null
katastrophenzustand ausgerufen
die noch waffen aus russischen beständen
das elfmeter tore pures glück erzeugen
profi mit den freiburger a junioren hat
zumindest zum erfolg geführt bei dieser
enthaltung zu entscheiden das ist schwer
der westhälfte die sonne im osten gibt
aber ob substanziell wirklich ruß an
verlangte auftritt vor gut einer halben
hilfen um eine milliarde der opposition
bislang wurden mindestens 4 148 menschen
hätten also solche die in der ukraine
kowitz strategie funktioniere so die
er die trophäe schließlich schon dreimal
offensiven dombach muss man sehen dass
stunde ist kann es dass scholz für die
es dichtere wolken besonders im
pest oder cholera zu wählen
schnell eingesetzt werden könnten auch
können wissen die favorisierten
nicht genug
sich wird durchsetzen können ist zu
gewonnen
presse getreten und hat sich zur
nordosten und hier und da kann es auch
die strategische lage etwas anders ist
tot aus trümmern und schlamm geborgen
bezweifeln vom don bass aus alles
botschaft wir haben alle zimmer und
potsdamerinnen spätestens seit gestern
ohne schulung die werde man im
wir halten es für erforderlich dass
mal ein bisschen regnen in den nächsten
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
die kandidatin der extremen rechten
das leben von tausenden es nach den
man hatte sie am beitrag schon gesehen
zunächst aber dürfen nach einem foul die
fußball-nationalspieler nico
kontrollieren bis runter zum strategisch
nachhinein beim nato partner dann durch
fenster mit schlössern ausgestattet das
schwere waffen geliefert werden das ist
geäußert nach einem telefonat mit
schlotterbeck steht laut medienberichten
tagen ändert sich am wetter wenig es
worten des präsidenten weiter gefährdet
eine sehr lange frontlinie und jetzt ein
arbeitet derweil vor allem an ihrem
so wichtigen mario pohl am asowschen
leverkusenerinnen vom punkt schießen
us-präsident beiden olaf scholz ist
westliche waffen ersetzen da stand
auch die meinung vieler in der koalition
vor dem wechsel vom sc freiburg zum bvb
wasser von keimen befreit und den boden
bleibt bei dem leichten bis mäßigen
in der provinz kwazulu natal wird weiter
massiver angriff wir hören auch von
image sie macht selfoss herz babys will
meer das ist wohl russisches minimalziel
blagojevich mit dem 10 die bayer fans
spürbar in regierungschef der sich
nordostwind über den norden ziehen
nur der kanzler äußert sich nicht und
nicht nur aus der union sondern auch aus
gereinigt
heftigen gefechten von einsätzen der
nach vermissten gesucht der wichtige
der 22 jährige nationalspieler hat den
menschlich und weniger radikal
erklären muss zu der auch aus den reihen
den parteien der ampel koalition
dafür müssen die einwohner der quasi
dichtere wolken im süden gibt es
doch die wut der shanghaier wächst im
träumen bis zu 83 minuten vom finale
ist auch nicht zu einer entscheidung in
luftwaffe der artillerie und das wird
erscheinen
hafen von durban bleibt bis auf weiteres
vorgeworfen worden zu zögerlich zu sein
der eigenen ampel koalition massiv unter
sonnenschein aber erst am samstag kann
schon zertrümmerten stadt weiter leiden
dortmund an demnach eine zusage für
der lage der bundeskanzler die spd tage
geschlossen aus südafrika berichtet
dann aber verursacht jessica wich einen
chinesischen netz schob ihren aufnahmen
ich bin zuversichtlich das volk
es dann im südwesten mal für ein kleines
beschuss geraten ist dort sogar ja
sich jetzt die nächsten tage zeigen ob
patricia wiedemeier berichtet vor einer
und sterben doch die im stahlwerk
seinen transfer im sommer gegeben beide
sandra theis
von polizisten die bürger festnehmen die
gewitter reichen bei 10 bis 21 grad
öffentlich als zauderer und zögerer
hand elfmeter für potsdam
lang unter druck sie verteidigten sich
unterstützt mich
eingeschlossenen letzten kämpfer ergeben
die russischen drucken vorstöße
rettungskräfte suchen nach überlebenden
vereine müssen sich jetzt noch über die
bezeichnet wird und auch deshalb hat
isabel kerschowski
bisher damit dass man tschechien
guten abend
sich trotz ultimatum nicht 3000 mann
new york rom will seiner konkurrenten
realisieren können sich halten können
behörden zwingen sie ihre wohnungen zu
ablösesumme einigen schauen wir mal was
überwindet anna klingt gerade so eins zu
doch inzwischen bergen sie fast nur noch
genehmigt habe panzer aus nva beständen
scholz wohlleben mehrfach die enge
und ob die ukraine ihr land verteidigen
verlassen
die zur schau gestellte harmlosigkeit
etwa sind das dazu kommen 1000
leichen es sind gefährliche einsätze vor
denn daraus soll eine quarantäne
abstimmung mit den verbündeten betont es
an die ukraine zu geben die bundeswehr
dabei raus und das wasser im sport dann
eins verlängerung in der kann keiner der
nicht durchgehen lassen heute griff er
zivilisten die belagerer drohen ihnen
unterkunft entstehen chinas führung
genau was auch morgen weht der wind
können das werden jetzt spannende tage
solle keine deutschen alleingänge geben
zwei tagen starben in einer ähnlichen
verfügt über keine weiterhin frei
sie scharf an
noch heute werde gestürmt eine ermüdung
beiden trainer jubeln das
meist aus nordost was das für unser
aktuell landet ein großteil der kritik
fürchtet im corona chaos zu versinken
situation eine taucherin und ihr suche
werden hier in der ukraine
verfügbaren waffen abgegeben werden
elfmeterschiessen muss also entscheiden
sie hat ihre fassade ein wenig geändert
streak der sich hier und im ganzen land
wetter bedeutet das erfahren sie gleich
was diesen krieg angeht und was diese
wenn
und sie waren in einem fluss in
aber im berliner kanzleramt
von katja hall war das heute journal
können deswegen muss jetzt die
quälend hinzieht die schuld daran gibt
und in dem hat leverkusen pech nach
um akzeptabler zu wirken aber sie
schwierigkeiten geraten insgesamt kamen
sie so weitermachen gibt es für china
zweite offensive wie es hier heißt wir
einschätzung von theo koll vielen dank
industrien müssen wie gesagt auch
moskau anderen die westlichen staaten
können sie um 22.15 sehen mit bettina
vertritt die alten ideen sie wird aus
latte siems trifft zum 4 2 im
mögliche andere lieferungen möglich
keine hoffnung mehr sagt der polizist zu
hunderte menschen ums leben 48 gelten
dem euro ohne es zu sagen das ist die
jetzt auch zeigen wird da meine class
versuchen alles um unsere militär
herr letzte nacht hat sie begonnen die
schausten und jetzt geht's erst mal
gemacht werden die koalitionspartner
extreme rechte
der festgenommenen frau wir werden bald
elfmeterschießen
aktuell als vermisst wir suchen nach
operation möglichst in die länge zu
meister aus kiew dankeschön und
weiter mit einem zdf spezial zum krieg
lang erwartete großoffensive von putins
potsdam im finale gegen wolfsburg und
grüne und fdp sähen das anders bleiben
ziehen das zeigen die gelieferten waffen
emanuel marco hat zuletzt in den
krieg mit amerika haben das wissen sie
in der ukraine machen sie es gut auf
unserer nachbarin sie wurde vom fluss
armee und der pro russischen verbände
ein zdf spezial zum krieg in der ukraine
damit provozieren die usa und ihre
umfragen ein wenig zugelegt weil der
bei ihrer forderung nach schweren waffen
doch nur die kommunistische partei kann
eine neue phase des krieges york kanzler
wiedersehen guten abend heute zogen die
davon gerissen wir sind uns dessen
abstand aber immer noch recht knapp ist
verbündeten das regime in kiew bis zum
können sie gleich nach dieser heute
meine forderung ist erstmal und mein
uns retten
sicher weil wir den körper ihres sohnes
waren nun zahlreiche künstler sportler
scholz meinte schauen wir auf die lage
sendung sehen wegen des ukraine krieges
die zustände in den provisorischen
wunsch dass der bundeskanzler sich jetzt
letzten ukraine weiter kämpfen zu lassen
schon gefunden haben sie aber noch nicht
im kampfgebiet
mal dafür ausspricht dass wir
und gewerkschafter vor marine le pen und
die frontlinien jeder russischen
quarantäne unterkünften sind oft
grundsätzlich schwere waffen liefern
senkt der internationale währungsfonds
die strom und trinkwasserversorgung sind
kiew seinerseits veröffentlichte bilder
artillerie möglicherweise panzer die
ihrer europafeindlichen haltung viel
seine prognosen für die weltwirtschaft
offensive im osten zieht sich über
verheerend dreckige toiletten
zeit drängt der krieg wartet nicht bis
hunderte kilometer vom nordosten bis
für dieses jahr um 0,8 punkte auf nur
wird abhängen von der tv debatte morgen
von hochmotivierten soldaten die im
teilweise unterbrochen viele füllen an
die menschen sind ein gefecht jeder der
südosten hier stoßen die angreifer laut
wir uns sortiert haben die
donbass auf die angreifer warten
noch 36 prozent für den gesamten
abend wenn es wird das einzige direkte
beschädigten leitungen eimer und
unionsparteien drohen nun damit den
positiv getestet wird muss in eine
beobachter sagen nicht nur um
ukrainischen angaben auf breiter linie
kanister andere sind auf tanklaster
euroraum rechnet der iwf jetzt mit
bundestag darüber abstimmen zu lassen
aufeinandertreffen der beiden
vor erklärtes ziel die region donetsk
quarantäne unterkunft egal ob er
verteidigung müsse es der ukrainischen
konkurrenten
geringeren wachstumsraten für russland
der cdu-vorsitzende märz dazu heute auf
angewiesen doch in manche gebiete
seite hierbei gehen auch darum möglichst
symptome hat oder nicht ist in der
und lohans komplett unter russische
und die ukraine sogar mit schweren
in den usa müssen die menschen in
konnten die helfer bislang noch nicht
viel russisch kontrollierte gebiet im
twitter der offen ausgetragene streit
rezessionen und die ohnehin schon hohe
kontrolle bringen schweren beschuss gab
flugzeugen zügen und bussen vor es keine
einmal vordringen für die einsatzkräfte
größten shanghais 50.000 betten es gibt
osten zurück zu erobern das ist wichtig
der koalition schadet dem ansehen
inflation dürfte der krieg weiteren
es an vielen stellen besonders leidet
gelten klare prioritäten
masken mehr tragen eine bundesrichterin
unseres landes in der ganzen welt aber
weil das ende des krieges wurde an die
keine ausreichende medizinische
darunter die zivilbevölkerung christoph
heizen
in florida erklärt die korona maßnahme
es gibt eine mehrheit im deutschen
versorgung erklärt sie uns
fürs als erstes kümmern wir uns um die
waffenstillstandslinie verläuft darüber
distel berichtet
mit spannung und bei vielen auch mit
bundestag auch für schwere waffen an die
für rechtswidrig mit der verfügung habe
entscheiden wird wie die ukraine in
ein sterbehospiz in der region donetsk
sofortige humanitäre hilfe um
ukraine jenseits von spd fdp und
zukunft fortbestehen wird in welchen
anspannung wird darauf geblickt wer am
es gibt keine warmen duschen das licht
die nationale gesundheitsbehörde ihre
eigentlich wollten diese menschen in
grenzen sie bestehen wird zwei seiten zu
sonntag nächster präsident oder nächste
sicherzustellen dass alle betroffenen in
befugnisse überschritten so die
linkspartei
ist die ganze nacht an shanghai im
würde ihr leben zu ende führen doch wer
begründung das weiße haus nannte die
präsidentin frankreichs wird in der
geld oder die lieferung schwerer waffen
sicherheit sind und eine basisversorgung
noch die kraft hat muss jetzt den nimbus
entscheidung enttäuschend und rief dazu
stichwahl amtsinhaber emanuel marco und
haben als zweites konzentrieren wir uns
oder beides der kanzler wird sich dieser
zur evakuierung zurückbleiben die ans
auf weiter maske zu tun gegen den
die rechtsextreme marien im falle einer
diskussion weiter helden müssen
bett gefesselten zu ihnen wird der krieg
[Musik]
[Applaus]